- So wait, you're
engaged. Congratulations.
- I am, thank you.
- That's exciting.
This is my favorite thing
to learn about you though.
Her name is Taylor.
What were the chances?
- We either keep it super
simple or super complicated.
- Okay. Do you go by Taylor?
And she goes by Tay?
- [Taylor] Yes.
- Okay. That makes it easier.
- Or a lot of people just
do boy Tay and girl Tay.
- Oh my God.
It sounds like you're in
Montessori. Like Pre-K.
- Yeah, but either Taylor and Tay,
or boy Tay, girl Tay, whatever works.
- How did y'all meet?
- Funny story, my sister
actually introduced us.
- Oh, I love that.
Your family approved first, that's nice.
- Yeah, it's just me and my sister.
So we're super close.
And she always said that
she was gonna introduce me
to my future wife and I was like, sure.
- Oh my gosh.
- But she actually did.
- [Kelly] That's so cool.
- Yeah. She was like
I have an idea, throw,
because I love game nights,
she's like throw a game night
invite me and some of my friends over.
And I'll bring Tay.
She'll just be one of them.
And you guys can just meet.
- [Kelly] Feel it out. And it worked out.
- We hit it off, and the rest is history.
- She should start a company
of setting people up.
So how did, how did you end up proposing?
- You know, Tay's awesome.
And this is one of the
things I love about her.
She's like, I don't want anything special.
I don't want anything grand.
Like, oh, I just want
like, do it in the kitchen.
Like I love to cook.
So I make us dinner all the time.
And she's like one night when we're just
like having dinner and a glass of wine
like that's all I want.
So I did do it in the kitchen
but I did it big in the kitchen.
I had it filled with flowers.
- [Kelly] We have this picture and I mean,
what are we talking about
with the flowers and the fire?
I love it.
And it's like, I love that
you have the neon sign.
You're like, are you into this last name?
- 'Cause we already share one name.
So it's gonna be extra complicated.
- Oh, my God.
I actually didn't think
about that till just now.
- I know, we're literally
going to be the same person.
- Oh my God. That's amazing.
I just thought of that.
- [Taylor] I'm a narcissist.
It's amazing. It's great. It'll be easier.